redondear 24.000 259 a la centena más
cercana a la centena más cercana podemos
ver que realizar este problema resultará
bastante simple pero lo que quiero hacer
en realidad es pensar que significa
redondear a la centena más cercana así
que déjenme dibujar una línea recta por
aquí abajo vamos a dibujar o marcar las
centenas sobre dicha línea vamos a
suponer que por aquí tenemos 24 mil 100
luego por acá tenemos 24 1200 luego 24
1300 y finalmente 24 mil 400 a esto me
refiero cuando hablo de incrementar en
centenas bueno ahora sobre esta línea
donde se encontraría el 24 mil 259 vemos
que 24 mil 259 estaría entre 24 1.200 y
24 mil 300 y como este intervalo es una
centena 59 estaría por aquí este punto
es 24 mil 259 así que cuando alguien nos
pide redondear
la más cercana literalmente se está
refiriendo a redondear a algunos de
estos incrementos de 100 o redondear al
incremento de 100 que esté más cerca si
miramos esto si simplemente le echamos
un vistazo podemos observar que está más
cerca de 24.300 que de 24.200 así que
cuando lo redondeamos lo haremos a
24.000 300 si redondeamos a la centena
más cercana
la respuesta es 24 mil 300 no siempre es
necesario utilizar la recta en este tipo
de problemas si lo prefieren está bien
pero existe otro proceso quizás un poco
más fácil más mecánico que consiste en
tomar este número 24 1.259 y como
queremos redondear a la centena más
cercana
buscamos el dígito que ocupa la posición
de las centenas que en este caso es el
número 2 y al decir que vamos a
redondear significa que queremos que los
dígitos a la derecha de esta posición
sean solamente ceros entonces nos vamos
a fijar en el dígito que está a la
derecha de la posición
queremos redondear
entonces nos fijamos en este y si este
número es igual a 5 o mayor a 5 10 5 6 7
8 ó 9 vamos a redondear hacia arriba así
que en esta situación redondeamos en 2
hacia arriba pues el dígito que está a
la derecha de las centenas es 5 así que
este número lo vamos a redondear a la
siguiente centena que sería 24.300 y
esto es a lo que me refiero cuando
decimos que redondeamos hacia arriba
ahora para poner un ejemplo contrario
digamos que tenemos 24 1.249 y de la
misma forma nos fijamos en nuestras
centenas tenemos el mismo número 2 y
ahora el dígito que está a la derecha de
la posición de las centenas que es el
número 4 no es igual o mayor que 5 así
que lo que vamos a hacer es redondear
hacia abajo y cuando digo redondear
hacia abajo debemos tener cuidado pues
esto no significa disminuir el número
que ocupa la centena vamos a redondear a
24.200 que es la centena más próxima
a 24.000 249 y esto tiene sentido pues
si vamos a la recta 24 1.249 se situaría
más o menos por aquí por este punto que
acabo de dibujar y podemos ver que 24
mil 249 si queda más cerca de 24 mil 200